broadcasting okay implementation science
for fast Diagnostics for bloodstream
infections in the role in antimicrobial
stewardship program a substantial
proportion of antibiotics used in
healthcare may be inappropriate
altogether unnecessary which can lead to
adverse drug reactions Clostridium
difficile infections and the development
of antibiotic resistance and one of the
major contributing factors is the delay
in standard lab procedures for blood
cultures anywhere from two to four days
for both the ID and sensitivity
resulting in overuse of empiric therapy
a new faster diagnostic tests from
accelerate diagnostic can provide both
the a phenotypic ID and the antibiotic
susceptibility test with the M IC s in
less than seven hours effective clinical
adoption can be done using
implementation science which provides
action-oriented and mission-driven
teamwork and enhance communication among
diverse clinical members so the
objectives of this posters describe
three tools used in clinical
implementation stages describe how
antimicrobial stewardship programs can
be more effective with the use of
implementation science and describe how
fast phenotypic diagnostics for
bloodstream infections can play a
significant role in reducing the
inappropriate use of antibiotics and
adverse outcomes so the description of
the project is that an antimicrobial
stewardship program they've been at the
forefront of the efforts to curtail
antibiotic inappropriate antibiotic use
but with faster blood culture
Diagnostics for organism ID and
susceptibilities clinicians can
deescalate or target appropriate
antibiotic therapy thereby reducing days
of therapy the costs mortality adverse
outcomes and length of stay the use of
implementation science can be an
effective method to guide clinicians and
clinical adoption sessions but
successfully use the fast Diagnostics
for blood cultures in septic patients so
the company established a clinical
intervention solutions team there is a
program manager who coordinates all of
the activities of the other
implementation specialists there is an
infection Preventionist epidemiologist
who conducts retrospective and
prospective
active chart reviews of anywhere from 25
to 30 cases of current patient care
continuum overlaid with the opportunity
for intervention and associated impact
there's also a data analyst that
evaluates the performance data post
verification we also have an ID pharmacy
consultancy service to provide clinical
education as needed at the facilities a
process engineer that evaluates the
processes and clinical pathways we also
have a clinical business justification
specialist that provides performance
data literature a quote contract
presentations and deliverables for the
clinical coach to share with your within
their organization and finally a
director of clinical adoption who guides
the clinical practice and the adoption
of this best phenotypic diagnostic test
and associated work and information
flows so under methods and approaches
during the exploration stage readiness
is assessed by a clinical intervention
solution team and includes
the retrospective chart review the
process analysis of the lab pharmacy
Texas disease services and infection
prevention and how they respond to blood
cultures a business analysis that uses
publicly reported metrics such as length
of stay mortality sepsis readmissions C
difficile infections and CMS penalties
for healthcare associated conditions and
following P analysis and diverse group
of clinicians are invited to the session
including ID physicians pharmacists
infection preventionists the
microbiology staff nursing staff sepsis
coordinators if they exist or critical
care nurses and physicians even
emergency department physicians may be
invited information technology
specialist and finally administrators
some of the tools that may be used are
mind mapping sessions to break down
silos within hospitals and develop some
teamwork and collaborative you know data
gathering of how their processes work
and then we have the team's work on
process pathways for their separate
areas and then report back to the team
we may develop a fishbone diagram which
is a very easy way to be able to present
to administrators the efforts of the
team and then a gap analysis and an
action plan with follow-up sessions to
ensure
implementation as an example example
under the gap analysis figure number
four we might find that the delivery to
the core lab for blood cultures is being
delayed or they're not incubating the
blood cultures properly or they're
leaving them for very long extended
periods of time due to lack of 24-hour
lab coverage a blood culture
identification is taking very long on
more than 24 hours while
susceptibilities are taking another two
to four days to be delivered to the
clinicians we may find that nurses have
difficulty contacting the ID position
due to lack of 24-hour coverage our
pharmacists have challenges working with
the ID physicians to respond to
de-escalation recommendations and then
we work with them to develop the further
desired states that they would like to
have at their facility some of the
lessons that we've learned as the
adoption of this faster phenotypic
diagnostic technology can decrease the
time to critical lab results and the use
of implementation science can maximize
the benefits of obtaining training this
fast ID and ASD result for optimizing
their antibiotic therapy and also for
the infection preventionists to
institute isolation precautions faster
for multiple drug-resistant organisms
since the standard lab procedures that
are delayed from two to four days end up
delaying the placement of patients who
have organisms like CRE or M RSA or BRE
on appropriate contact precautions so I
want to thank you for listening to the
poster presentation
you